[Music]
okay welcome everybody for people coming
in well find a place my name is Derek my
last name is pronounced Howard if you
were wondering spoke on Friday with a
few foreign people who had a problem
with it and I'm gonna tell you about a
project that I did at the company I work
at but they designed this there in the
data science and engineering team and we
with our team solved one of our business
problems using machine learning and
unsurprisingly we do that with deep
learning now there's a lot of people
I've been talking about deep learning
how to train your models those type of
things I'm not necessarily going to talk
about that I'm more gonna tell about how
we went from while trying one of these
things out to having it fully run in
production and solving the problem I
suppose and if you have questions please
save them for the end and if I make some
weird noises with my nose and it's
because it's hay fever season and I'm
really suffering from it which is kind
of ironic because I work at this big
flower and plant the company which is a
global marketplace for flowers and
plants it's actually the biggest flower
auction in the world and yeah what we we
were founded a long time ago and through
a series of mergers and eventually this
company was left as the biggest and it's
a it's actually founded by the growers
themselves to have well did I actually
add multiple reasons but one of them was
to have like joined forces and I have a
stronger position in the market on the
sell side I suppose we auction 6.7
billion flowers plants and flowers every
year and that's not even counting all
the direct sales you can it'll probably
come up somewhere in the 12 billions of
flowers and plants that go through our
company so that's a lot of logistics and
transactions I also have some other
bursting stats so about 50,000 people
from all over the world come to visit us
so you can imagine if 50,000 people will
show up at your office they end out
the surface area of all our channels
combined is bigger than the service area
of Monaco so that tells you something
about the scale and the Aalsmeer
building is actually the biggest
building in the world
counting my footprint and it has four
bus stop so I can actually take the bus
to lunch if I want to I don't do that
actually but some people take their cars
sometimes sitting ahead okay so what is
royal floral what do we do how does it
work basically what happens the growers
people who grow the plants they deliver
the plants to us to one of our sites so
this is one one hole and this is
actually a fraction of what's coming in
every day it's but yeah there's flowers
and plants as far as the eye can see
what then happens is that it's auctioned
in one well there are six of these rooms
where the growers are sitting and the
plants well sometimes the plants come by
and for flowers not so much actually and
then there's the auction clock its
auctioned by a Dutch auction system I
will explain it later and then what you
see here it's not VIP boxes it's
actually the auctioneers that lead the
auction and on top of that there's also
people from all over the world entering
the bidding process so remotely so you
don't have to actually have to be
physically present in one of these halls
now what then happens is one of the most
fun things to watch everyday that is
that well everything that has come in is
salt and it has to be distributed to
well the people who bought it so it's
not like somebody well you can actually
buy one of these food carts but usually
it's bought by multiple people so it
needs to be distributed to everyone and
and it's actually done by humans and
well this is maybe not even a busy day
but it's really amazing how they managed
to not collide with each other in there
it's really it's really fun to watch you
can actually you can just walk into the
building and any day you have to get up
early but yeah you can you can see it
for yourself so the first well the first
auctions first was I was was made was
made in the end of 1911 and the first
flowers they sold they sold in a pub in
a bar and what happened is that they put
all the flowers on a pool table and the
auctioneer would just shout some price
it will start high
and then would lower the prices over
time and then the first person who says
mine will get the flowers for that price
and the system is called a Dutch auction
and it's actually still today still the
the well not today but still the the
process that is used only nowadays to
use a clock so they started using it so
you see all the flowers coming by and
the clock goes down in the first person
who wants to buy the flowers at that
price gets it so over time of course it
got a bit modernized so now we have the
stands and the flowers come by the
stands and the clock later on it got
modernized a bit more and nowadays it's
actually fully digitized system and
people can on their laptop also join
this there's 35 separate clocks on which
people can bid and what you also see
nowadays is that the plants actually
don't go through the through the stands
anymore and especially people remotely
can also not see it so that's a problem
and this is the problem we're solving
because what the auction then decided
was that everybody has to supply
mandatory has to supply a picture of the
goods that they deliver now you can
imagine that taking quality pictures is
not per se a priority for all the
growers so it's a it's really hard to
compare if everybody takes them
differently so they came up with some
standards at with day at which they have
to adhere the pictures so the buyers can
better see what they are buying one
other reason for having these standards
is that these pictures also go to web
shops and you don't want like this whole
rainbow of various picture types on
there which are actually selling the
same product so that's not a good
property so there has to be some
standards which we all agree on
examples of these requirements of
standards are for example that if you
sell a single plant that there has to be
a ruler on the photo because then you
can see our baked plant this or once
they are sold in it in a tray then the
tray also has to be on the photo because
then you can see it and the background
also has to be like a white background
or for white flowers may be gray but
definitely not black because it gives
you also different perception of what is
actually being sold so we get a lot of
flowers we sell a lot of flowers and
people buy a lot of flowers
can imagine that checking all of these
images by hand is not really feasible
project it's actually what's happening
before we did it but they can no way
check everyday all the other pictures
that are coming in so at that point it
was decided let's use computer vision or
something in that area to to determine
whether these pictures meet the
requirements or not so that's where the
data science and data engineering team
comes in which I'm part of
unsurprisingly everybody issues in this
image I noticed we started working with
Garros in terms of flow so basically
what you do is you put four different
properties we put the training data and
we train a neural net and then something
comes out of it but we didn't of course
construct real neural net we use the pre
train at work in this case Fiji g16 we
used and what we do is the well-known
transfer learning trick so we take the
pre train Network you cut off his head
and then you train the last few layers
again based on your training data for
the people who have been on the tutorial
so Friday is they all know how to do
this now I suppose but yeah then we can
for each model we can train our own
network we put this whole thing in in
this box you made sort of a console
application out of it so you can just
point it to the training data and for
every property on a picture we can then
train a separate neural net now there's
something you should know about our team
we we do a lot of things and one of the
things we take great pride in is that we
name basically everything that we built
and I'm my background in computer
scientists if earlene could build
science and we're really terrible at
naming things so hopefully maybe like a
kind of judge which are the good names
today this particular item was named
Mariana and it was named Mariana because
Mariana because of the Mariana Trench
because it's the deepest point in the
ocean or on the earth and you can guess
the connection is really terrible people
it gets worse trust me
so one thing is good to notice that not
every problem has to be solved by deep
learning I suppose we have some
properties that are in itself easier to
solve so what we also did and what I
further will not really talk about any
more today is that we also have a euro-6
base approach with simpler machine
learning models like insight could learn
or something like that that is pretty
much similar thing to mariana exit it's
not deep learning we call it her eager
because it's something our boss calls
when he came up with the greatest
statistic in his in his career I'm
looking at your demco if you see this
then yeah it's very proud of it so what
these two things do is well they
generate models we feed them with
training data and they generate models
for every property well for all kinds of
properties so these are nine and I think
we'll will expand very quickly in the
next week in the near future what you
don't need to do is of course well
people need to start using it but they
can't because they don't know how to run
a deep learning model so obviously we
slap an API on it
and that API we place in a docker
container which is really good too
altogether using the environment and to
deploy it easily and we're very flexible
that way and this particular component
we named a magical because it magically
extracts all these features from from
the images yes I don't know so what does
a magical do you can send an image to it
and it went down for each of the models
for each of the properties that we're
looking at it will return this jason
with well it's not a probability but
with like a score for how or if that
object is available or is present in the
picture or not now that's great that we
have this but it doesn't say if that
picture is correct or not so for that we
also need the actual rules that the
business people have made so the court
further standards and we need some
metadata about what supposedly should be
in the picture and so we also need a
product code and a first code so first
is basically the container that is in so
in this case it's a tray and based on
all that information we can then decide
okay this photo is correct or not we
also built a component for depth and an
API so we put the rules in there it
actually also calls some other services
which contain information about the
products based on the product code and
that component also calls a magical asks
are these properties really in the
picture and based on that it can make a
decision so it's basically a decision
engine we named this component Judy and
yes it was named Judy because of the
Judge Judy because yeah it's a decision
engine and it decides North High School
you can imagine our our meetings about
this okay so now we have the system in
place and it runs and it's great but we
are of course not done because it's not
like it works and it was great testing
this but there's like we know what
training set like accurate it is how
well we are able to extract these things
from the test set but we don't know
actually and we don't know still don't
know anything about the real world
actually accuracy and also probably when
we implement these people will start to
provide better images because they get a
lot of feedback and say well this is
[ __ ] image please provide the better one
and so we also want to keep our models
to go with their time and kind of update
themselves to get higher standards so we
need to get some kind of feedback so we
built a feedback API for that it's
called VOC after the image catalog and
basically what you do to that if you
send an image to it with the labels for
all the properties or a subset of them
and it will hash the image based on the
content use a image Heights library for
that and then it stores the image on s3
and with the labels with it and so we
can get some feedback but of course like
there's a quality team that does these
checks checks the images checks also if
what's on the image is actually what's
also delivered on the card cards and all
I actually joined them once to see how
they work and you have to get out of
that really really really early and then
you're in the freezer at really low
temperatures without the nice jackets
because you didn't think of anyone
but anyway I walked with these people
and they are of course not people who
are like the work maybe 40 years at the
company they're they're not gonna send
images to the API or take an image so
what they actually do in the morning is
they go into the system where all the
other things that are delivered are
listed they export an excel sheet and
then they well it's a subset of
everything that's been delivered because
they can't handle everything and
basically they go through the through
the refrigerators or cool cells and they
will check like if what's on the on the
cart is actually also on the image in
that system now what we built is a tool
for them to help and do these checks so
it's really great and we named it
excellent yes so basically what happens
is that they can upload the excel the
things that they are going to check to
this it contains all the information we
will take that information and then send
all of the items one by one we send them
to Judy actually I have flipped no don't
we signed by Judy and then we generate
these these switches where you can press
yeah or you get a prediction of Judy and
you can also change it if you think it's
not correct and once you do it's
actually send back to Foulke
so and in that way we get really I think
this is really important step for
bringing any model to production is that
you have this feedback loop in it I
think that's really a key I think
Yanis yesterday talks about it I think I
think it was honest and it's really good
so what you get now is both from for
each and every single model we get like
an overview for images that are correct
according to that person and that are
incorrect so we can also see something
about or we get the training data but we
can also see how how its balanced and
what we also get is the predictions of
Judy we also store so we can also see
how our model is predicting things like
in terms of how its distributed over the
over the score so if it's really skewed
to one side or the other side or gets
like that over time we can actually
actively monitor it and then I really
think this is really key key piece in
our infrastructure talking about the
architecture or the infrastructure
itself this is an image we created and
so what we get is we have a magical we
have Judy I hope it's really visible but
you have a magical we have Judy
we have vogue and all the it's AP is RBI
T it's all deployed on AWS and it's
deployed behind the APA API gateway and
we have the single sign-on solution is
called octa and the api gateway does all
the security for us so I don't know if
Melanie is still in the room please
don't hack us I think it's secure let's
don't do it so what we can do from that
is that all the systems all the use
cases everybody wants to use this API
can just go through the API authenticate
we have control of who can do that and
then they can access our API so if
people send that image to VOC it's
stored on s3 and then well we use air
flow this is really a nice set up for us
because the next talk will also be
irrelevant but we can in air flow we can
schedule something that says every week
please retrain the models based on the
new training data or something like that
it can fire up some tasks the models
will be stored in artifactory
which you also have a managed managed
service we can also store big files in
there and then in the end if that's
successful if we are confident that what
the strengths should go to production we
we we trigger a deploy in a magical gets
updated with all the models I think
that's really really cool you can forget
a bit about this part cause it's really
due to legacy and platform things that
we build it like that excellent
has the back end right here it yeah it
uses to keep state uses dynamodb we call
that Jason Bourne because it stores JSON
objects we also have something for
another project
it's called Steven Steven sequel it's
also anyway the front end this house is
on some other place but don't really
care about it all the logging and
monitoring we just use the locks go to
s3 and we use cloud watch for metrics
and we're fond ofor dashboarding yeah I
think it's cool
I haven't told anything yet about what
API we use I don't really have time for
it but we experimented with sanic
because you can see that a lot of it's a
no senac or who doesn't know who knows
and not a lot of people okay it's really
comparable to flask but it's a sink
Cannell asynchronous requests and you
see that we have a lot of i/o and
network requests and we thought it would
really benefit from that like if you
want to know more about this ask me in
the end or come find me but yeah we are
we now have this architecture it works
it runs and we get feedback so we can
monitor model performance but there's of
course also the performance of of the
whole thing itself well the big
powerhouse of this whole thing isn't
magical because that runs the actual
deep learning stuff and we noticed when
we were doing this locally it was pretty
fast we were pretty pretty ok with it
but when we put it in the cloud on some
ECS cluster it was actually very slow it
was like more than one and a half second
slow and we were not really happy with
that so we started investigating ok why
why is this the case so what happens in
a magical is this you send an image it
reads and parses the image it resizes it
to fit the network the pre tray or the
neural net specifications we then run it
through the through the neural net
layers the VDD 16 layers and then what
comes out of this we can use multiple
times for the end of the last layers for
every model right so it's it's actually
actually coding sequentially but of
course not like the output does not go
through this foot but this is what
happening so we started to measuring
which step cost a lot of time and we
found that actually like the vast
majority of the time was was what's in
Fiji 16 parts and so one of the things
we learned because we started this a
while back and tensorflow
I think first thing we were using was
1.4 release candidate we didn't upgrade
the tensorflow to 1.8 and it went from
like 1 and I have 1600 milliseconds to
900 950 so that was a really big
improvement in speed so if you have
anything running in production
be sure to check this what evel's of
course not fast enough so we
investigated further and while we we
tried use different instance types on
Amazon to check what the performance was
and what you notice so this was our ECS
cluster which is used by the whole
department actually when we put it on
there it's pretty
it's pretty slow but we then tried
larger engines assist with more course
and it started to pick up speed and
really became a lot faster so tens it
flow of course getting more of course it
will be it will become faster and what
we also tried are a few GPU instances we
can actually run a docker container on a
GPU insist on Amazon and it can use the
GPU for processing and it's really like
you can see it it was really fast so if
you put it on this p3 instance it went
if you if you think we did this probably
in a week all of this this benchmarking
and it went from 1600 milliseconds to
under 50 that's like a lot of first
Peter which we're really happy with also
Amazon has elastic GPU so we thought
well this is really cool we can just
attach elastic GPU to whatever something
but it's only available for Windows
machines so if you're ok we're doing
that and go ahead but we are not the one
thing of course like you don't get
there's no such thing as a free lunch
we've heard it multiple times
you also have costs so I use now the on
demand pricing as a as a proxy for this
but what you see is that this p3
instance is by far the fastest but it's
also really really expensive what what
is nice though is that you have like
this sort of equal pricing year while
performance goes up so if you make a
price performance comparison chart which
I did you can see which instance is
actually most cost-effective and you
would see that the p2 a GPU instance is
actually if you process a 100k images
sequentially and this is definitely the
cheapest option but this is of course
like a this is not like a realistic
scenario we wouldn't always have 100k
images to process all day long so yeah
you need to do like you come into the
topic of scaling so if this is our load
like the blue line and we have actually
we have a batch load like all the stuff
that comes in it's being delivered every
day but we also have a photo app in
which people can take photo and
instantly get an answer is this a
correct image or not and those are two
different use cases one we don't really
have to process it really quick and
we do want to process really quick
anyway if you want to go into the batch
load we can of course just put up a
really big fast machine really expensive
one and it would definitely be able to
handle your load the problem is well
your batch load is going down you're
still paying a lot of money to have this
super expensive machine running and
super fast machine so what you also can
do is pick a smaller machines like
multiple smaller machines and then like
you can kind of scale with your load and
it's far more cost-effective but you
take a penalty of course in your
response time because it will be slower
to handle all the fiji tensorflow start
and that's also not for us a good
property so we're trying to now find
like a you know middle ground where we
do have some form of performance in
terms of response time but we don't
really but but we still have like a
cost-effective solution and we're
looking into multiple things so i we're
not really done with this part I guess
and so you can put it on easy s without
scaling we looked into Fargate which is
a new amazon thing i can basically run
containers and don't have to care about
clusters so it's nicer easy as I suppose
but it didn't have you can only run four
cores per container I think so that's
not maybe maybe in the future they will
increase it next talk will be about
given ATIS I don't know who the speaker
is I haven't seen him but I'll
definitely go there to check what's
going on there and I think the direction
that we are actually moving is Amazon
spot fleet so you can basically tell
demos all I need this much processing
power it'll check which instances are
now really cheap in terms of spot
pricing and it will then spin up enough
spot instances to give you that to be
able to give you that processing power
that you need that you need so some key
learnings I suppose we've gone from this
small real-world problem into I think a
mature solution I think we're quite
successful in that and I think it's good
that you're involved and to answer your
you start talking with the business
about this problem and in the end for
also making sure that the feedback loop
is okay I'm monitoring that our models
are really good sometimes here if people
in companies that are Dale scientists
and then
they get thrown this problem of okay
please find a cooler in this image and
then once they have a model that does
this they throw it over to the next team
or to whatever and somebody else handles
it I think it's really cool that we get
to be involved in all of this and we
have a team of engineers and scientists
who cooperate in this I think it's
really good
what's also good I think that we did is
that we we iterated over this this
process for the way that I told you is
also about how we are we did it so we
get with this we deliver something every
now and then and it looks good because
we can also demo it to people and the
effect of demoing things a lot to people
is that everybody gets on board
everybody gets excited and people
actually come with new use cases for
your for your solution actually so we
started with one problem and we solved
it but in the end we actually solved
maybe multiple problems because people
were like what is cool I want this so
I'm also important to really be involved
with the end users we're solving a
business problem we're not really
looking to okay let's do a cool
tensorflow project and let's just go
ahead with it and and make us look good
as a team we actually want to add some
value with this with this whole thing
and well once again can stress it think
about monitoring your models I guess one
other thing well microservices docker is
great I don't think I have to tell this
crowd and think everybody pretty much
does stuff with docker and especially
the maintainability part what we also
want to do is create our own docker
image with this API stuff in it and so
all our dependencies in like related to
the API part we can just manage in one
place instead of updating multiple
components and also manage services I
think it's also really great you don't
want to spend a lot of time in the Deaf
opening your role they're all stuff so
if something is managed and you can use
it use it also don't throw deep learning
at every problem again it's not the
solution to to everything and sometimes
something simpler works as well or
something else works even better
definitely had to say this because when
Cal told me to and well last but not
least the key learning if you get the
chance to name all your all here all
your components is really like it really
makes you meetings better and especially
when people come and join your meeting
from outside who don't know about them
they're like what is this about there's
this Judy thing and yeah it's really I
think it's really amazing it takes the
funding it keeps the funnier project I
guess that was it thank you so thank you
dick that was the best talk I've ever
seen about naming conventions some
people might say it was excellent we
have plenty of time we have like five
minutes for questions easy so what might
be the easiest way yes so I hope to
question the first ones to consider
predicting the category of you know a
plant so you can make the quality
check-in process more automatic another
one so today today Oh considering you
know today consider compiling tensorflow
in your I don't know virtual machine so
to make it run the faster yeah okay so
I'll start with the second question
because it's we thought about it yes we
haven't done it yet like I think now
that we have the whole system in place
and we can measure everything and
actually next week or this week is the
kickoff where people start to give us
the training data we can actually look
at this kind of optimizations in the
real world with without getting all the
all the feedback and also this is
definitely something we want to do so
multiple outputs compiled yes also we
want to try different retrained models
so currently using PG 16 but maybe
something else is faster or better we
can definitely look into that the first
question remind me types of plants oh
yeah types of plants yes I had also very
good answer for that we actually had an
incubator and we visited that and there
were some startup busy or busy
processing these things and determining
which plant was on the picture generally
this is not really a problem for us
because if a buyer sends us plants and
he delivers roses but they are in fact
tulips or something else
somebody will if the quality team
doesn't see it which because I can't
check everything then the customer will
get delivered tulips instead of roses
and will very quickly be on the phone
like this is not roses this is tulips
and it will fix itself like grouse
generally don't give wrong information
about products now first like The
Container it's delivered in that is
actually a problem and that happens a
lot where people put and run first coats
or run run type but that's also
something we we can capture with this
right now so we train for different
types of containers so yes okay next
question
yep really nice presentation what is the
business case what can you save really
curious about the numbers about you mean
you talk money right or I guess there's
two things so one is customer
satisfaction is at least one of the the
value cases I would suppose so
if the quality gets better if the images
are better generally okay like if you
want to buy something a nice computer
you can buy a computer that has been
photographed in some dark alley
somewhere with I know maybe few drug
addicts lying around oh yeah I've like
you have like Apple who gives you this
super shiny thing with all the chimes
and whatnot and generally you'll buy
that faster I suppose if the price well
it's comparable so that's one thing like
it's just easier for everybody to
compare all these plants and generally
that that increases customer
satisfaction and maybe also the prices
and the other thing is that well if we
need to have a quality team with a large
size to check all of these things that's
really like people are more expensive
than this tensorflow framework so if we
can if we can capture and just more of
the of these things and help them and
steer them in the right direction that
will definitely make their job easier
better and faster
do you measure the effect of the
feedback loop the effect improvement
well yes but what do you mean exactly
like we measure what what what the
models predict we measure what people
say and then we can you can say
something about the real-world accuracy
like how good are we yeah how good is it
after you have like a feedback that I
cannot tell you because this week will
actually like it the kickoff was
supposed to happen past week so then I
would have all the numbers here for you
but now we have been evaluating it in
the past few weeks and we have been like
few people have been running it and
working with it and now on next week I
have to instruct basically the whole
team to start using it then we like we
get really the size I guess to say this
but currently I cannot I cannot give you
a number unfortunately but like from
training data and stuff we were like
upper like 1995 upper region so I think
we can get it like like we're actually
more it's not necessarily maybe about
accuracy of how for each like if you
just can't are we correct about this
plant or not what we're actually really
looking for maybe it's the wrong ones
you want to be able to identify the
wrong ones and I think false positives
are are not as bad but false negatives
are so I don't know we have like
training accuracy is really not really
predicted for the real world accuracy
that we're looking for so it's it's
something I cannot tell right now
because we simply don't have enough data
yet what's the usual reason that the
feedback says your prediction is not
right is about specific objects you're
predicting or determination sorry sorry
so does your mother you have different
items you want to protect if it's there
and then you're trying to combine them
to say if the pictures you do not so
according to the feedback what's the
usual reason they find your mother is
not good so yeah we do measure for like
of course we measure it on like a
picture as a whole but we also measure
it for each specific models
I think I get differs a bit for plants
the rules are somewhat less strict and
everybody's already maybe doing it good
so the usual things are that like they
have a miniature plant or they put a
logo somewhere where they're not
supposed to and those type of things but
for flowers it's really people get
really creative and they make this they
have like professional photo
photographers and and and Photoshop
people and they make this whole piece of
art which looks really nice but when you
show it to our model it's like what is
this thing and all kinds of things show
up that are wrong and and and well in
the end it leads to that the picture is
has to be looked at by somebody so
that's good I suppose but I think those
type of pictures are now the artists
because they're not really adhering to
the standards but we picked them out
anyway so it's really we are running out
of time and we would love to hear more
names and stuff but that has to happen
in the break we all give it one last
final applause - there
[Applause]